the killer of an elderly couple in
california could be freed from prison
next year if a state appeals court rules
in his favor daniel marsh murdered
oliver northrup and his wife claudia
maupin in 2013 when he was 15 years old
but a state law passed in 2018 prohibits
anyone under 16 from being tried as an
adult and that could include him 48
hours correspondent erin moriarty has
been following this story for years erin
good morning it is very concerning good
morning we're still waiting on the
court's decision in this case and this
is why it matters there's a belief in
this country based on research that
young criminals can and should be
rehabilitated but california authorities
say that daniel marsh may be an
exception
daniel marsh now 24 years old is asking
for an early release from prison it's an
appealable judgment under 1237.
on wednesday his attorney mark greenberg
argued before a remote panel of judges
that march had never been tried and
convicted as an adult despite the
horrific crime that he committed when he
was just 15.
master bedroom in 2013
marsh in search of victims climbed
through an open window into the home of
87 year old oliver northup and his wife
76 year old claudia maupin the elderly
couple was asleep when marsh stabbed
northup 61 times maupin 67. the case
went unsolved for two months until
police got a tip from a teenager who
heard marsh brag about the crime what
are you reporting double homicide
marsh first denied any involvement
but after more than three hours of
questioning by then fbi agent chris
campion marsh admitted the unimaginable
every time
i look at someone
in my mind i see flashes of images of me
killing them
and he appeared to show no remorse
i'm not going to lie
amazing
that's why yolo county district attorney
jeff reisig charged marsh as an adult it
was the most horrific depraved murder
i've ever seen as the district attorney
in this county
in 2014 marsh was convicted on two
counts of first-degree murder and
sentenced to 52 years to life but four
years later the california legislature
passed a law which prohibits any
offender under the age of 16
from being tried as an adult no matter
how violent the crime his lawyer wants
him to be included in that law
retroactively
the california deputy attorney general
rochelle newcombe argued marsha's
verdict was final in 2018
and he shouldn't be allowed to drag the
victim's family through never-ending
appeals appellants murders in this case
have resulted in endless challenges for
the victims families friends and the
community but thankfully the law and the
facts that ensure appellant's continued
incarceration are uncomplicated and
straightforward i don't want to do it
anymore i want
to rest i want my mom to rest i want my
family to rest the victim's family
watching from the district attorney's
office now wait nervously for a decision
this
man could be out on my street in less
than a year
and there is absolutely nothing i can do
about that every morning for the last
six weeks when i wake up my first
thought is terror
the court's decision on marsha's future
could come at any time and if the court
rules for march he could be released as
early as may 2022 next year when he
turns 25 years old in earlier hearings
he said he's no longer a threat but he's
been diagnosed as a psychopath and
experts who have assessed him are
divided over whether he could be
rehabilitated that's terrifying it's a
tough one it's a tough one to hear the
family has to hear him say it felt
amazing to kill them he looked so
innocent as a teenager clearly not aaron
thank you